merci d'être là merci une formidable
occasion de parler de l'intelligence
artificielle avec un des pères on peut
dire ça vous êtes un des perles oui Père
parrain
aux États-Unis
[Musique]
est une formidable occasion de faire le
tour de tout ça de l'histoire d'un
intelligence artificielle
mais j'aimerais commencer par une
question toute simple qu'est-ce que
l'intelligence il y a le cas consentante
sur la définition personne ne s'entend
sur la définition mais c'est en tout cas
en ce qui concerne les les êtres vivants
c'est les capacités à percevoir à
raisonner prendre une décision et
ensuite agir c'est surtout agir en fait
qui est important et l'équivalent pour
les ordinateurs c'est pas seulement pour
des robots qui puissent s'agir mais
aussi pour des agents virtuels qui
puissent répondre à des questions par
exemple etc résoudre des problèmes et
pour l'instant c'est très bien faire le
côté perception un petit peu le côté
action mais pas du tout le côté
raisonnement bon parce que le cerveau
vous vous dites vous avez dit dans
plusieurs interviews un jour la machine
va égaler et même dépasser le cerveau
humain vous êtes sûr de ça ça ne fait
aucun doute c'est une question de temps
aucun doute aucun doute c'est vraiment
de temps on n'a pas la technologie
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on n'a même
pas les principes de base ni la science
qui est nécessaire pour atteindre ça
sauf dans des domaines très précis
c'est-à-dire on peut faire des des
systèmes qui sont super intelligents
dans certains domaines assez étroits
mais on n'a pas système qui soit
intelligent dans tous les domaines ou
les humains sont intelligents pour
l'instant mais il y a pas quelque chose
de mystérieux qui se passe à notre
cerveau avec un amas d'éléments sains
mais qui produisent des choses très
compliquées qui fait que la machine ne
pourra jamais reproduire ça non
c'est tout simple parce que d'un point
de vue théorique au niveau de
l'informatique il y a qu'une manière de
faire du calcul en fait il y en a deux
il y a le calcul classique et le calcul
quantique mais si on s'en tient au
calcul classique
des ordinateurs suffisamment généraux
généraux peuvent imiter
en fait n'importe quel type de calcul et
ce qui se passe dans le cerveau c'est le
calcul donc on peut le reproduire mais
ce qui est compliqué à reproduire sur ce
sur quoi on travaille depuis des
décennies déjà c'est les capacités
d'apprentissage et vous vous êtes
beaucoup là-dedans le déplarening
apprendre à la machine à apprendre pour
vous nous expliquer ce concept-là de
façon simple alors il y a une motivation
très simple c'est que
je ne me considère pas et c'est
intelligent pour concevoir une machine
intelligente et je pense que c'est vrai
pour tout le monde donc la meilleure
manière de construire une machine
intelligente en fait c'est de la laisser
se construire elle-même par
apprentissage est-ce qu'on constate
c'est que dans la nature n'importe quel
animal qui a un cerveau peut apprendre
même ceux qui n'ont pas de cerveau
peuvent s'adapter donc c'est une
caractéristique vraiment essentielle de
de la de la vie c'est l'adaptation et la
capacité d'apprentissage donc reproduire
cette fonction là permettrait aux
machines de devenir intelligentes on
apprenant et non pas en étant
directement programmé et un phénomène
vraiment intéressant dans le dans la
biologie c'est que l'intell émergent de
du cerveau qui est un réseau de très
nombreux neurones des cellules très
simples en fait qui sont
des 86 milliards pour vous et moi
peut-être un peu moins pour moi je sais
pas et qui sont interconnectés qui ont
des milliers ou des dizaines de milliers
de connexions avec d'autres neurones et
c'est le le changement la modification
de l'efficacité de ces connexions qui
fait qu'on apprend à chaque quand on
apprend quelque chose on change les
connexions entre nos neurones et on est
capable aujourd'hui de de simuler sur
des ordinateurs des réseaux neurones de
ce type là avec des centaines de
milliards de ces connexions
est-ce que c'est une révolution
l'intelligence artificielle au même type
que l'imprimerie que la vapeur que
l'informatique est-ce que c'est du même
type pour vous c'est clair il y a nous
vivons au cœur d'une révolution oui
alors la révolution est annoncée c'est à
dire que ça a été une évolution jusqu'à
présent c'est qu'on n'a pas encore de
machine qui sont vraiment supérieurement
intelligentes elles vont nous aider dans
notre vie tous les jours c'est déjà le
cas
l'intelligence artificielle et utilisée
à très grande échelle par exemple dans
les réseaux sociaux dans tout ce qui est
service en ligne moteur de recherche etc
pour faire le tri d'information le la
modération contenu etc donc c'est
absolument massif c'est utiliser bien
sûr maintenant en médecine en imagerie
dans la science et puis
l'utilisation tous les jours dont les
gens se rendent peut-être pas compte
quand on a un système dans la voiture
qui permet à la voiture de conduire
automatiquement sur l'autoroute c'est un
réseau de nous signaler un obstacle un
obstacle de Fred et automatiquement un
obstacle donc ça sauve des vies
aujourd'hui et ça c'est vraiment entre
autres votre rapport vous il y a le cas
c'est que la machine puisse reconnaître
une image c'est quand même donner des
yeux à une machine quand même
extraordinaire là
la perception et ça c'est les premiers
progrès dans ce domaine date de la fin
des années 80 donc ça remonte pas hier
on a on a commencé à construire ces
réseaux neurones sur une architecture un
petit peu particulière architecture ça
veut dire de quelle manière connecter
ces neurones aux autres avant
l'entraîner et on s'est inspiré de la
structure du cortex visuel pour pour
connecter ces neurones et on a été
capable
il y a plus de 30 ans d'entraîner des
systèmes à reconnaître des formes
simples comme par exemple des chiffres
ou des caractères manuscrits vous avez
vous travaillez sur les chèques voilà
maintenant c'est pour nous c'est une
évidence qu'une machine peut lire un
nombre évident au début que lire l'échec
peut lire les les enveloppes les codes
postaux les adresses etc donc tout ça
c'est fait automatiquement maintenant et
ça a commencé fin des années 80 début
des années 90 d'ailleurs
mon ami Joe avec collaboré à ce projet
alors qu'il travaillait avec moi belle
aventuriste dans YouTube et ça qu'une
machine puisse voir c'est le début
ces systèmes sont très utiles pour
l'assistance à l'écriture mais par
contre ils ne sont pas vraiment
intelligents c'est à dire que des
systèmes coachs GPT j'ai pété 4 et
autres ne comprennent pas comment
fonctionne le monde ils sont entièrement
trade entraînés sur du texte et la
plupart de la connaissance humaine en
fait n'est pas textuelle du tout c'est
notre expérience du monde
ils inventent des affabulent des bêtises
ils ne peuvent pas vraiment raisonner ni
planifier expliquer aux gens comment en
fait ce que ça fait c'est que la machine
apprend tout ce qui s'écrit sur la
planète en fait tout ce qui est sur
Internet 10 milliards de mots à peu près
à peu près j'imagine plus que ça plus
que ça et ensuite si on pose une
question de charger pitié faites moi un
exposé sur les mouches à chevreuil au
Québec mais là elle va mettre des mots
qui lui semblent logique
pas logique c'est des mots qui
correspondrait c'est ici statistiquement
est-ce que ce sur quoi la machine était
en train de parce que la manière la
machine est entraînée serait simple on
prend un texte on enlève le dernier mot
du texte et on entraîne la machine à
prédire ce dernier mot d'accord et puis
on fait ça avec des milliers de
milliards de segments de texte c'est
entre 1 et 2
milliers de milliards et à force de de
faire ça à la machine apprend en fait
comment prédire le mot suivant dans un
texte et donc on peut l'utiliser pour
prédire le mot suivant puis ensuite le
mot suivant etc etc on réinjectant les
mots prédits dans l'ordre même être
dépasse bientôt en fait c'est pas ça oui
donc c'est système bien sûr sont utiles
à l'heure actuelle mais ils ont des tas
de problèmes raconte des bêtises ils
peuvent pas vendre planifier ils
comprennent pas comment fonctionne le
monde etc donc il y a une autre
révolution qui va venir bientôt sur
laquelle on travaille tous pour essayer
de donner à ces machines des capacités
de comprendre le monde réel c'est à dire
s'entraîner pas seulement sur du texte
mais aussi sur la vidéo par exemple et
puis avoir des capacités de raisonnement
de planification qui caractérise
vraiment l'intelligence pour faire quoi
pour faire tout c'est à dire comment
s'est-il par exemple qu'on a des
systèmes comme chat GPT qui peuvent
réussir un examen au barreau ou quelque
chose comme ça qui est essentiellement
de la recherche d'information mais par
contre on n'a pas de robot qui permet de
débarrasser la table et d'Empire la
vaisselle alors que n'importe quel
enfant de 10 ans est capable d'apprendre
ça en quelques minutes on a toujours pas
de voiture qui se conduisent toutes
seules complètement alors que n'importe
quel adolescent est capable d'apprendre
ça en une vingtaine d'heures donc c'est
très clair qu'il nous manque quelque
chose de vraiment fondamental dans les
la capacité des humains et des animaux à
apprendre qu'on ne sait pas encore
reproduire avec les machines on y
travaille c'est ça vous avez dit la
machine peut faire des choses très
complexes à dire à prendre des textes et
mettre des mots en ordre mais ne peut
pas se lever à les mettre une assiette
dans la vaisselle ça prend la dextérité
ça prend une vision mais ça ça sera
possible d'avoir un assistant qui va
faire ça à la maison ce sera possible la
question c'est combien de temps ça va
prendre ça je peux pas répondre à cette
question
parce que ça va dépendre du de
grands progrès qu'on doit faire dans les
années qui viennent les emplois perdus
on a fait beaucoup de cas parce que des
études 300 millions peu importe les
gagne quelles sont les gagnants et les
perdants il y a le cas alors
certainement comme tout technologie ou
transformation technologique les métiers
vont déplacer c'est-à-dire des métiers
vont disparaître d'autres vont
apparaître la plupart des métiers que
les gens vont faire qui sont en demande
dans 10-20 ans on a aucune idée
aujourd'hui de ce que ça peut être de
même que il y avait un temps on pouvait
pas imaginer que vous pouvez gagner sa
vie en étant youtubeur ou influencer ou
même développeurs d'applications mobiles
on ne peut pas imaginer qu'elles vont
être les métiers du futur
dû au fait que l'intelligence
artificielle va se va se développer en
fait on peut imaginer un futur dans
lequel tout un chacun
interagira avec le monde numérique
essentiellement à travers un assistant
intelligent et qui nous aidera dans nos
vies tous les jours et ce sera un petit
peu comme à voir un assistant humain ou
même un staff de gens intelligent plus
intelligents que nous qui travaillent
avec nous mais sur la planète d'un
quarante il y aura les gens qui auront
l'assistant intelligent puis d'autres
qui n'auront pas parce qu'on crée pas
une terre encore à deux vitesses alors
là ça dépend de des options qu'on va
prendre dans un futur très très proche
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des gens qui
considèrent que l'intelligence
artificielle peut être et peut-être trop
dangereuse et donc il faut pas la mettre
toutes les mains il faut les garder dans
un coffre-fort avec une clé et ne
laisser que certaines personnes
avoir la possibilité de développer des
des systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
et puis une autre option qui est au
contraire la recherche ouverte avec des
plateformes Open Source un petit peu
comme la structure de l'Internet
aujourd'hui qui est basé sur des sur des
des standards ouverts et moi je très
très en faveur de la deuxième option
parce que je pense que
l'IAA va
produire une nouvelle renaissance pour
l'humanité enfin amplifier
l'intelligence humaine ça peut être que
bon être segment et oui il y a des
dangers mais on aura des contreesures
pour contre ces dangers vous êtes
résolument optimiste contrairement à
votre collègue qui a gagné le Prix la
même année que vous qui est à Montréal
Benjo je suis à Benjo qui a signé avec
d'autres je voulais une petite phrase là
la mitigation des risques d'extinction
liée à l'IA devrait être une priorité
mondiale ou même titre que d'autres
risques à l'échelle de la société comme
les pandémies la guerre nucléaire donc
ils y vont fort des gens qui connaissent
autant que vous il y a comment se
fait-il qu'ils arrivent en conclusion si
différente que la vôtre alors ça dépend
de la confiance qu'on a dans la
dynamique de la société a exploité une
technologie d'un côté positif ou négatif
et
j'étais très surpris en fait de la
position du Yoshua qui est un vieil ami
on est d'accord sur beaucoup de choses
en l'occurrence pas là dessus c'est à
dire que moi je pense que
si on est on peut toujours imaginer des
scénarios catastrophes par milliers mais
en fait les sociétés sont
s'adaptent et trouvent toujours des
solutions à des problèmes majeurs comme
ça donc moi je vois plutôt ça comme au
contraire une renaissance l'intelligence
artificielle qui est là pour amplifier
la connaissance et l'intelligence
humaine assimiler ça à des pathogènes ou
des armes nucléaires je pense est un
contresens complet c'est-à-dire c'est
intrinsèquement bon les gens
intelligents sinon on dirait pas à
l'école mais en même temps quand la
Chine a la technologie de reconnaissance
faciale elle accroît son pouvoir sur ses
citoyens quand la Russie peut envoyer
des fausses informations grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle partout elle
accroît son pouvoir donc il y a des
dangers qu'on voit même aujourd'hui le
meilleur protection contre ces dangers
et la force de nos institutions
démocratiques
on a la chance d'être de vivre dans des
démocraties libérales qui font en sorte
que les utilisations de la technologie
sont soit pour le bien-être des citoyens
et limite les utilisations négatives
donc vous êtes content moratoire de
recherche contre pour un moratoire sur
la recherche oui oui bien sûr je suis
contre une illusion ça ne sert à rien et
au contraire même ça ralentit en fait le
progrès vers des systèmes plus de
sécuriser et performant êtes-vous pour
une réglementation
sévère partout en Europe ou en Amérique
alors ça dépend quelle réglementation et
c'est encore un peu tôt c'est-à-dire je
suis pour des réglementations
d'applications si vous faites un système
d'assistance à la conduite pour les
voitures il faut évidemment le tester le
certifier qu'une agence gouvernementale
qui autorise la mise sur le marché
pareil pour des médicaments ou des
systèmes de diagnostic médical mais mais
pas réglementé la recherche elle-même
mais mais si notre assistant personnel a
une caméra forcément le robot le
prochain robot il voit que on dit à
notre patron je suis je suis malade je
n'entre pas au bureau je raccroche mais
mon robot voit que je ne suis pas malade
et envoie cette photo là mon patron
c'est des il y a 1000 possibilités de
d'assaillir notre vie privée revendait
ce robot acheter en un qui peut-être
votre vie privée donc ça sera possible
de paramétrer de alors bien sûr les les
produits
il y aura quelques dérèglements bien sûr
pour protéger les données privées ça
existe déjà donc un robot de ce type là
on freinerait ses règles qui existent
déjà dans la plupart des pays c'est un
c'est plus ou moins fort donc ça prend
des règles ça prend des règles bien sûr
pour les produits on vous avait pas vous
mais à la communauté poser des questions
ça c'était la première lettre vous
souvenez les 1000 scientifiques je vous
je vous reposer trois de ces questions
la très simple devrions-nous laisser les
machines inonder nos canaux
d'informations de propagande et de
contre-vérité
alors seulement si ces machines et ces
plateformes sont ouvertes c'est à dire
transparentes et imaginez Wikipédia
Wikipédia est une source d'information
pour la plupart des gens dans le monde à
part en Chine et la raison pour laquelle
on a une certaine confiance dans
Wikipédia c'est que le processus par
lequel Wikipédia est créé et Cratos
comme on dit au mot français c'est à
dire des millions de gens qui
contribuent et puis toute une hiérarchie
de d'éditeur là qui qui vérifie le
contenu à mon avis les systèmes
intelligents du futur devront être
construits de la même façon c'est-à-dire
doivent être ouvert avec des
contributions de millions de gens alors
que si ils sont propriétaires fermés et
contrôlés par un petit nombre de
compagnies dans la Silicon Valley c'est
là qu'il y a un problème
devrions-nous développer des esprits
non-humains qui pourraient
éventuellement être plus nombreux plus
intelligent et nous remplacer absolument
bien sûr ah oui pas nous remplacer mais
plus intelligent plus nombreux oui parce
que ça amplifie notre intelligence
maintenant la question c'est est-ce que
ces systèmes vaudront se mettre en
compétition avec nous ou est-ce qu'elles
seront à nos services et
je pense qu'un problème que beaucoup de
gens ont c'est que ils ne peuvent pas
imaginer qui est une intelligence
supérieure à la nôtre qui n'est pas
aussi tous les problèmes de la nature
humaine c'est-à-dire la volonté de
dominer
curiosité et la violence etc alors qu'en
fait on construit ces machines donc on
va les construire de telle manière à ce
qu'elle soit soumise à l'humanité d'une
part et
contrainte pour ne pouvoir avoir que des
comportements sécurisés j'appelle ça
objectif en anglais et on a un design
ensemble mais bon
intelligence sortir de notre orbite
ok bon je vais donner un exemple dans
l'humanité il y a des gens qui qui
veulent dominer et puis il y a des gens
intelligents c'est pas les mêmes je
travaille dans un laboratoire de
recherche la plupart des gens qui
travaillent avec moi sont plus
intelligents que moi et je vous le dis
tout de suite ils veulent pas me ils
veulent pas mon job ils veulent pas le
job de joie Pinot qui dirige
le laboratoire de recherche de l'État
sans vouloir dominer halle dans 2001
au-dessus de l'espace quand même prendre
le contrôle de vos films préférés
[Musique]
des astronautes bon tout ça donc la
machine on a cette peur-là en nous là
cette machine là a peur de désactiver
parce que elle a compris que on allait
désactiver donc c'est un problème cette
idée que une machine aurait peur des
désactivée spontanément même si on ne
construit pas en elle
le l'instinct de préservation de enfin
l'instinct de survie or
même dans le monde animal c'est pas vrai
il y a des tas d'animaux qui n'ont pas
l'instinct de survie certains moments de
leur vie une pieuvre par exemple
une fois que c'est
les bébés ont éclos meurent
immédiatement en terminant des questions
un peu en rafale est-ce que une machine
pourra avoir conscience qu'elle est une
machine et qui a des humains est-ce que
une machine pourra avoir une forme de
conscience c'est probable oui c'est
presque certain
la question c'est qu'on ne sait pas
vraiment définir ce que c'est que la
conscience
vous êtes conscient de votre de votre
âme bon un chimpanzé conscient peut-être
un éléphant un lion un chat une souris à
quel moment on commence à avoir la
conscience quelque chose de particulier
dans l'architecture du cerveau qui fait
que on a cette illusion de la conscience
est-ce que les machines en auront besoin
c'est pas clair mais c'est très possible
une machine pourrait j'avais posé la
question madame Pineau il y a quelques
années ce que le machine pourrait créer
une oeuvre aussi extraordinaire qui est
Requiem de forêt ou de Mozart très
possible aussi la question est de savoir
bon c'est pas pour tout de suite
aujourd'hui on a des systèmes qui
peuvent en fait synthétiser la musique
alors oui il s'est mis beaucoup parce
qu'ils sont entraînés sur tout un tas de
de musique existantes et ce qu'on peut
faire aujourd'hui il y avait un système
produit par nos collègues musique Jane
on tape un texte et le système produit
une musique qui correspond à ce texte en
médecine ça peut être fabuleux les
progrès l'intelligence artificielle
s'assume une évidence en terminant
est-ce que tout invention votre esprit
est bonne non bon atomique
c'est un petit peu difficile de savoir
ce qui serait passé sans la bombe
atomique mais on n'a pas eu de guerre
majeure entre des entre des grandes
puissances depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale donc
est-ce grâce à la bombe atomique ou en
dépit de la vie est-ce que l'IA par
exemple dans ces développements de ces
premiers mois ou prochaine année est-ce
que ça pourrait aider l'Ukraine à
repousser la Russie de l'invasion
ou non donc même le développement des
armes n'est pas intrinsèquement une
mauvaise chose avec avec l'audience
artificielle les Ukrainiens en ce moment
utilisent massivement des drones qui
sont pas du tout fait pour la guerre
pour pour repousser les attaques des
Russes
doit-on interdire d'utiliser l'IA pour
piloter ses drôles
dans 50 ans ce que c'est un robot qui
aura composé mes questions ou c'est moi
encore et vous qui allez répondre je
pense que
c'est vous qui les poserez c'est moi ou
un succès qui qui répondra mais par
contre vous l'assistance d'un robot pour
pour les écrire et puis pour vous dire
bon est-ce que c'est une briquet si vous
pas une bonne question je pense que on
aura tous comme je dis précédemment des
assistants intelligents c'est comme
avoir un staff mais un staff déjà donc
c'est pas très très différent oui mais
j'ai lu votre livre moi j'écris mes
notes j'ai barbouillé j'ai fait des
dessins mais il y a le cas votre livre
est vraiment fascinant il sort au Québec
début juillet quand la machine apprend
parce que vous faites vraiment bien
l'histoire de tout ça et c'est quand
même accessible moi j'ai arrêté mes
maths quand même assez tôt et j'ai quand
même pu suivre merci beaucoup de nous
avoir je vous remercie bonne suite